okay all right thank you for coming to
this talk for its building advanced and
native Rick's this is not the the
meeting stock which I think is in room
four and so hopefully you're in the
right room I so just to introduce myself
I am lace Lou Franco I am a senior
software engineer at Microsoft as part
of the commercial software engineering
team and I'm based in Melbourne and I
focus more more slea round data
specifically around spark so I'm here to
present to you around spark specifically
as your data breaks so just a quick
survey who here has actually used spark
okay we have a few folks yeah who has
here has heard of data breaks okay you
said the bit played with it nah okay
that's all right so I'm actually gonna
start off with some basics first so you
should have some understanding of the
key capabilities of spark and I sure
date the bricks specifically spark on
your data bricks and I'm also gonna walk
you through an advanced analytics
workload running on top of azure data
bricks so here's the agenda so if you've
never done spark that's okay I'm
actually gonna start from the basics but
we just ten minutes talking about what
spark what did what the internals of
spark and then I'll move into the meat
of the talk which is add your data
bricks and I'll be doing this in a way
where I'm actually walking you through
an actual pipeline and I've built on top
of the platform so without further ado
so if you've ever done some work in the
big data space you probably recognize
some of these logos and the thing that I
want you to notice is that it's a very
heterogeneous set of tooling that in
order to get any end-to-end pipeline on
the with the big data tooling set you
actually have to learn four or five six
tools so if you wanted to do sequel on
Hadoop you probably needed to do five if
you need it to some subscripting or ETL
you needed to do big machine learning
there was mahute for streaming there a
storm and flink for graph there was grf
so in order for a data scientist and a
data engineer to actually get something
substantially running they needed to
actually write four or five different
frame right on top of four or five
different frameworks so enter Apache
spark
so Apache spark is this unified
computing engine which could do
everything that you saw in the previous
slide
so when Apache spark came out in 2014 it
was fairly groundbreaking in its
performance and also its functionality
so you can see that in Apache spark it
gives you these libraries on top of a
set of core unified libraries so you
have spark sequel it can do streaming it
has a machine learning library built in
out of the box and even can do graph and
on top of this it has a number of
language bindings so fork is actually
written in scala so you'd expect that it
has a scholar API and a Java API but it
also provides a Python in our API so for
the data scientists in the crowd you'll
also notice that it's actually built on
top of its you also know these are just
a computing engine so compared to Hadoop
if you're familiar with Hadoop it's
actually a computing engine and a file
system so you have MapReduce and HDFS
SPARC is just the computing engine so
lots of the times folks would actually
have Hadoop as in HDFS installed and
they would install SPARC on top of it so
SPARC can reach into different file
systems as you can see here blob storage
s3 HBase and Cassandra and other and
many other things
okay so spark when SPARC was developed
and released around in 2014 so it's
actually quite relatively new it was
almost pegged as it was it was built in
response to the limitations of hadoop
mapreduce so the reason why MapReduce is
fairly slow is that every mapper
actually has to write intermediary
results to disk so every mapper and
reducer has to write intermediate
results of this in which in the next
stage actually picks it up now SPARC
actually tries to do most things in
memory which is why it's much faster and
so almost any so all narrow
transformations in SPARC is done
exclusively in memory and the great
thing about SPARC is also it gives the
ability to cache data the specific set
so you'd imagine lots of the iterative
algorithms especially machine learning
algorithms actually go through your data
multiple times
so by cashing your data at specific
steps in inside your pipeline your smart
doesn't have to reach back into disk and
on top of all these improvements Park
has been benchmarked to be around 10 200
times faster than classic MapReduce ok
so digging deeper into the SPARC API so
you're if you've ever done SPARC you've
probably heard of the RDD which is the
resilient distributed data set that's
the fundamental building blocks of SPARC
and ultimately all of this API actually
compiles down to in an RDD in one shape
or form
now that was when spark came out the
version one point X of SPARC now at 2.0
2.0 and beyond do spark came out with
the dataframe and data set api which is
a higher level abstraction on top of our
DDS now the advice moving forward is to
use this higher level abstraction
because you inherit all the optimization
that comes out of the box you don't get
that with the RDD api and the only
reason you would probably use already
the api is if you find this obscure use
case in which case you can't use the
higher-level ones
okay so here's a slice of a spark
application the most important part of
an application a spark application is
arguably the driver so this is your
heart of your application this is where
your spark session lives and that's
essentially your gateway to the spark
cluster and that's also how you would
actually communicate with spark where
you run your user code and so on now the
driver is in charge of analyzing and
distributing your job across your
cluster and giving you tasks to the
executors the executors are all they do
is the tree get some fast food Driver
execute report back to their status to
the driver spark can also work with
different cluster managers so in the
wild you probably find Hadoop yarn
that's a very popular way of running
SPARC because usually customers really
high already have a hadoop installation
I just want to install its mark on top
of it but SPARC also comes out of the
box with its own cluster manager so you
don't have the hard dependencies on
it also works on on top of Apache mesas
and the fun fact is the creator of spark
is also a co-creator of Apache Mesa so
he's quite a smart dude now the other
thing I want to draw your attention to
is the data structure so that's a spark
that's essentially an RDD and/or spark
data frame depending which API you're
using and if you're a new developer a
very common pitfall is that you wanna
convey you have pandas or psych it or
yeah and you're trying to manipulate
your spark data frame and you find that
your libraries don't work with spark
data frames so the first thing you try
to do is actually convert it to a
panda's data frame that's not a not a
good idea because you can see here your
panda's data frame is living in the
driver that's one node and your spark
data frame is literally spread across
your cluster so the moment you convert
your spark mater frame into a panda's
data frame you're literally collecting a
billion rows back into that one little
tiny node so that's a very common
pitfall when you start starting with
spark it might work with small data sets
but the moment you deploy the production
it almost guarantee will blow up okay so
that's pretty much spark in a nutshell
I'm just gonna shift gears now to data
brakes so what is data brakes data
bricks is essentially a managed apache
spark platform with a number of tooling
built out of the box it's a first party
service on Azure it's not something you
would spin up from the azure marketplace
and it comes with all kinds of
integrations with Azure as you would
imagine so as your ad data connectors it
hooks up to your billing so you have a
single pane of glass for your billing
and of course you can also view data on
data breaks using power bi now instead
of talking about beta breaks it's
actually easier to show it so I'll just
gonna shift here okay so in order to
actually create add your data break so
I'm just here in the azure portal and I
just literally searched for Azure data
bricks I hit create here and it shows up
this pane and I just literally I
literally
entered my workspace name pick my
subscription and resource group location
and there's a pricing tier of different
tiers within data bricks so the standard
here the premium tier is essentially
your standard Deerwood but with
role-based access so that's pretty much
it
so you hit create it creates a workspace
pretty simply and once you get to your
workspace just say ok hmm internets
interestingly slow but you will find
this button just launched workspace and
that will launch this workspace of azure
data break so this is pretty much your
data breaks portal the first thing you
want to do in native bricks is actually
to create a cluster so to create a
cluster you just go to clusters and
create cluster and you give your cluster
a name so lace cluster you pick which
cluster type you want to actually create
so the high concurrency cluster if you
have a multi-user sort of scenario
standard is for single users so I'm just
gonna click the standard and you can
pick different runtimes in your data
bricks data bricks runtime version so
which Maps the different spark versions
and different libraries that may come
installed there is a GPU cluster just
cluster with GPUs and there's an CPU
only cluster and in fact that beta class
version actually wasn't there yesterday
so that's actually quite new yeah so you
pick your cluster version you pick your
python version so python 3 is probably a
better choice and here is when you have
to know a little bit about the SPARC
architecture so you have your driver and
your worker so remember it's the back to
previous slides you pick your driver
size and you pick a specific VM your
worker size and the great thing about
data breaks it has this auto scaling
feature so which is very which is not
available hdinsight if you're familiar
with that technology so spark spark
native bricks will actually detect if
there's any back pressures in your in
your spark job and it will automatically
sail your cluster depending on the
parameters you set here
and the other cool thing is that it has
auto termination which will literally
kill your cluster if it detects it that
it's idle for a set given amount of time
which is a great feature if you've ever
forgot to turn off your hdinsight
cluster you can also customize your
cluster by specifying some configuration
inspark some environment variables you
can add your cluster for building
purposes and you can ship your logs to a
location within BBFS which i will talk
about in a second you can also customize
your clusters further by specifying an
init script which is basically a bash
script which will run every time your
cluster starts so there's some you know
obscure library that you want to install
this is probably the way to do it okay
so I already have a cluster installed so
I'm not gonna go through I'm not
actually gonna create a cluster there so
the thing with data breaks is that it
has this thing called your workspace
which is a list of your notebooks and if
you're ever familiar with Jupiter
notebooks it's very similar so I have a
notebook interface right here and the
second thing that you want to do once
you open your notebook is actually
attach it to a cluster so I already have
a cluster running and it's attached this
notebook set that should that cluster
now data breaks exposes the SPARC
session already through the variable
called spark and you can see that's my
spark session right there I can inspect
the version of spark which is 2.3 and
Here I am just creating a simple spark
data frame so and just displaying it on
data breaks so data breaks gives us this
nice sort of table UI out of the box
which you don't necessarily get out some
from other notebook technologies you can
print the schema and the great thing
about data breaks is that you can also
mix and match different languages so you
can notice you know this this is a
Python notebook and here I'm actually
gonna mix in some sparks equal so this
command literally just creates a
temporary view on top of my data frame
and then I can then use sequel to query
my data frame so if you're more familiar
with sequel you can use spark sequel
within your same notebook okay so the
other important thing about spark
but you need to realize is how it
actually executes spark has this thing
called transformation and actions so
transformation so our TDS are actually
immutable the only way you can change
your RDB is actually feed it to a
transformation and it spits out a nutri
RDD a brand new I did RTD so you're
effectively creating what they call a
dag add a gov execution so directing
directed a cyclic graph of executions
and then the moment you actually want to
view your data smart will then execute
the graph and then give you your data so
SPARC is essentially lazy in that sense
so here I have my data frame and I'm
just doing a set of transformation so
I'm just doing selects group wise and
average and spark hasn't actually
executed it it just says yep I got peer
transformation I know what I'm supposed
to do and then when I actually do an
action where I am collecting back the
results that's when spark actually
executes now this is very important to
realize because sometimes you would
execute you know five 10 cells and the
bug that you the bug in your code is
actually in cell number one and you're
ready at cell number 10 and then when
you trigger the action you only find out
that's it's already it's already passed
your bug so that's probably something
probably one of the biggest hurdles when
you're starting off developing in spark
ok so jumping back to my slides so that
was a nice sort of quick overview of
spark and data breaks
ok so Google actually published this
very interesting paper and it's it was
called the hidden technical depth in ml
systems and the entire idea is that your
ml code is actually this tiny little
piece of code in your greater ml
production system and in order to
productionize machine learning models
there's actually a lot of more work than
just the sexy algorithm that your data
scientists produced so that's
essentially the gap that data breaks is
trying to solve so it provides you this
unified workspace that that that makes
the production izing of machine learning
models much easier or at least with less
friction so not only do you get a
optimize data breaks smart runtime you
also get the ability to product
nice this notebooks to create
multi-stage pipelines to do a job to
schedule it using a job scheduler and
some notifications out of the box and as
you saw in the workspace it gives you
this collaborative sort of environment
where different data scientists
engineers and business analysts could
actually use and not only that you also
get if you step a little bit backwards
you could also see that later breaks
rigs up with all the different adjure
services so it can consume data from
Kafka and event hubs it can read data
from cosmos eco data warehouse blob
storage and data Lake and you can even
orchestrate your date urine matrix
notebooks using data factory which you
might want to do if you have some other
downstream components that you want to
run aside from your data bricks
notebooks and of course you can also
visualize using power bi okay so core
concepts so you've seen clusters
workspaces and notebooks the other thing
that you probably would want to know
about this job's which is your data
bricks job scheduler where he can
schedule notebooks to run at a specific
interval tables which I will go through
in second which is kind of like hive if
you are familiar with hive where you can
define essentially see sparks equal
tables and persist them in your data
picks workspace you can save sensitive
keys in the form of data break secrets
and you can upload third-party libraries
in the form of libraries in data bricks
now the other thing that you also want
to be aware of is the file system within
data bricks so this is essentially
similar to HDFS but really it's just a
layer on top of blob storage as far as
data bricks it's sorry it's it's
implemented now the great thing about
this is that it's not tightly coupled
with your cluster so that if you delete
your cluster your data is still there so
and spark data breaks gives you all of
these utilities to actually access data
in dbfs you can use it using the
different api's but it also gives you a
CLI and some utilities within your data
breaks workspace okay so with that
usually the first thing that I do when I
spin up a workspace is I actually mount
my blob storage
out-of-the-box it actually comes with a
blob storage with your workspace but
guidance is that you want to actually
attach a separate blob storage or it may
be your date that's already in this
other blob storage that's not that came
with data bricks okay so I have here a
notebook and as you can see the first
few two lines of code I'm just
retrieving data break brick secret which
I've defined earlier so this is my
storage account and key and if I let me
just first attach that and if I try to
execute this you'll notice that the
storage key is actually gonna be
redacted there so it so when it prints
out in you know your logs you want see
your key printed out in your logs now
this is the command of actually mounting
data bricks
so remember DB details that was the
utility command in the slides that's
available out of the box in your
notebook and I'm just calling the FS
mount command and I'm passing data
bricks my storage account and all of
this configuration the mount path could
be just something like mount that blob
storage which is basically a file for
file folder within your dbfs environment
and then I'm just passing my storage key
and I'm not gonna run this because I've
already mounted it and the rest of the
notebook is just me downloading the data
for the demo so that's pretty much how
easy it is to mount a filesystem
in data bricks and in order to see that
you actually made of bricks actually
come provides you with a command-line
dbfs so I'm just doing DFS LS and the
where I mounted my blob storage and that
should show me the files that are living
in blob storage once it returns but I'll
just show you blob storage which is has
data and models so this should return
okay I think the Internet's struggling
at this point perhaps someone's
downloading a gigantic docker in image
in the other room but that should return
basically and it will list out the files
that you see here that's pretty much it
okay that's me typing okay so moving on
okay so for this for the rest of the
slides I'm actually gonna be focusing on
the specific data set
it's the kdd 1999 intrusion network
intrusion data set is a very common data
set used for anomaly detection intrusion
Network detection so I'm essentially
going to build an anomaly detection
pipeline or natural data brakes now the
thing with this data set I just want to
throw it out there at the start is that
it's actually not super representative
of the real world because nobody's in
the data set this actually has more has
more anomalies than the actual normal
data and it was it's a bit synthetic and
synthetic in that way but I just chose
anomaly detection because it's quite
easy to understand intuitively and
without me further explaining it okay so
here's the architecture that I'm
actually building so I will go through
all of these steps one by one so you
obviously have to load your data explore
your data train your model and then you
want to actually operationalize your
model on data bricks so in order to load
your model usually lots of people use
spark spark sequel for the ETL jobs so
spark sequel is essentially the
interface to schwarz interface to
working with structured and
semi-structured data so it it's built on
top of your data frames and data sets
API and it provides you ODBC and JDBC
access as you would imagine so where
that lives in my demo it's around is
here and I will just jump back to my
workspace and I'll open that notebook
okay so here as you can see I am just
creating Oh
excuse me doesn't seem to be shooing
sorry I'll die okay okay there you go
all right sorry okay so basically okay
I'm just here in my spark EPL notebook
so I'm just literally creating a set of
tables using the create tables syntax
and you'll notice that it's very similar
to sequel so here I'm just specifying on
my table definition and I'm saying it's
a CSV file living in blob storage and
it's living in this specific location in
blob storage and you'll notice that
that's my mountain path by specifying a
location in my create table statement it
says that this is an external table just
you create a pointer to that specific
location now after creating the pointer
or an unmanaged table by spark sequel I
can then create my actual table and then
I'll just load my my pointer into that
actual table using this statement and
then I'm just dropping my temporary
table and refreshing so it's a fairly
simple pattern within data bricks and
I'm doing exactly the same thing with my
other data set so a fairly simple table
just to see your standard C test at a
execution and if I go to the data tab
you could see that all my tables are now
loaded so this is persisted in spark
data bricks and you can see that you can
very view your your table your data here
and I just want to show you that
okay I just want to show you that okay I
think there's just some network issues
okay I just wanted to show you that it
actually supports handling erase within
tables so you can actually embed Jason
within your values so it it does handle
semi structured data okay
so jumping back to the slides okay so
this is actually the meat of the top
which is the machine learning librarian
table bar called ml Dib now Emma Lib
comes out of the box with different ml
algorithms as you would imagine so
clustering classification regression and
even collaborative filtering and it also
provides you out of the box with
different feature extracting feature
extractor and transformation methods and
also probably the most powerful feature
is your mo pipelines which is very
similar to the API that you find inside
kit so digging deeper into the concepts
of MLM so you start off with your data
frame so it's built on top of your spark
data frame API and then you have these
set of transformers and estimators so
these are higher level abstractions of
the different operations that you can do
with your data frame with an ml Lib and
idea is you can also it also has a
standard way of passing parameters using
a parameter map and idea is is that you
can wrap a set of transformers and
estimators in what we call a pipeline
and this pipeline you can take as a unit
and then use it to transform your data
and compose really fairly complex
transformations fairly simply now you
might be wondering what's the difference
between a transformer and estimator so a
transformer as you would imagine is very
simple you would just it feeds it picks
in a data frame and transform it
transforms into a new data frame so
probably the most simplest transformer
you could think of it's a binary server
you gets a column of values it's
normally not a normally and it
turns it to zeros and once an estimator
slightly more complex because it takes a
data frame and it spits out a
transformer and the way to think about
it this that's actually your model so
you could think you fit a an estimator
it spits out a trained model which is
now a transformer which you can use to
make predictions on your data so that's
that's how you would think about it now
almost everything within sparked Emma
lived is either a transformer or an
estimator where we like 90 percent of it
so you can see that there's a fairly
feature-rich
library but let's say you had some
obscure logic or some specific model
that wasn't available it's also fairly
extensible so you can write your own
custom transformers and estimators in
fact Microsoft did exactly that with FML
spark which is a set of custom
transformers and estimators written for
for data science so it provides deep
learning support on spark and also other
data science tools that I thought was
quite useful which was not available in
built in MLM and there's this driving
community of third-party spark packages
not just MLM but also for the other
api's which essentially is extend spark
which I encourage you to check out so
okay so for the demo I'm just gonna show
you how to explore data and actually
train your model with spark MLM
okay so I am back here in data bricks
and I'm just gonna load my explore data
notebook okay
so I've already run this notebook but
I'll just walk you through it so I'm
just reading my data my kdd data and I'm
just displaying my data so and
investigating it I can print the schema
checking all the columns you can do a
count it's a fairly relatively small
data set around 1.7 million rows and
here I'm just doing summary statistics
so count mean standard deviation 50 25
50 75 percentile and so on and I'm
simply just doing a group by between the
anomalous and none of the most data
points so you can see that normally the
data points are actually larger than the
actual normal their disappoints so it's
a fairly synthetic data set it was
actually created using real TCP
connections but they literally have over
created the anomalous data points as you
can see here and I'm just breaking down
the different types of anomalous data
set data points into their pipes because
it's actually broken down it's actually
labeled two different types of anomalies
so the normal data set it's actually the
highest and the second one is smurf
attack which I'm not a network guru but
apparently that's something it's got
like a DDoS attack for for intrusion
detection trojan gurus out there so yeah
so and the rest of them are fairly small
data points so it's a fairly skewed data
set in that regard now I'm just gonna
shift through the training of training
actual the model so here I am I've
loaded my different spark ml libraries
and just specifying a bunch of variables
on the top and I'm loading my data like
here now I am actually defining now my
features estimators and transformer so
if
you're not much of a if you're not the
data signs that's okay so but if you are
you probably recognize a number of these
so the one hot encoding scaling your
feature so that it falls within a
specific range and probably labeling
you're changing your feature from a from
strings into into categories and
indexing it back to strings so that's
all of these feature create feature
estimators and transformers and you'll
notice that I'm actually just defining
them I'm actually not using them yet now
I can actually compose my pipeline here
so you can see that I have this this new
pipeline statement and I'm setting the
stages given the different features and
estimators and transformers that I
defined up top and Here I am calling the
fit function so the pipeline is actually
in an estimator itself which is an fit
function which then return and then
gives me a transformer which then I can
call transform on so that's all what
this is doing so I'm transforming my
clean DF into this transform DF and then
I'm splitting my data between the
between my my train and test set and
that gives me a good sort of training
set to start with to start training my
model so the first model that I'm
actually training is a gbt or gradient
boosted tree binary classification which
will classify if it's anomalous or not
the anomalous I'm defining my estimator
aka gbt classifier here and I'm just
calling fit given the data and now I
have my fitted model and I'm just doing
your usual evaluation which is your area
under the curve and so on and that
actually did quite well I think it did
like 99% accuracy
so it's this data set it's actually it's
a fairly trivial data set to fit on the
other thing you can do is actually chain
a fairly complex pipeline like you see
here so the previous models I was
actually setting out the data
transformation and the model training
you can train a chain that entire thing
into one gigantic pipeline like like so
and he
I'm just using random forests and here
is where I'm defining all my pipeline
stages fitting the pipeline and doing my
motor class evaluation the other thing
you can do is cross validation so which
is basically looping through different
polls within your data to actually tune
your parameters and Here I am you can
also use cross-validation within
pipelines so that's that
so that's supported now once you've once
the data scientist is finished working
and are happy with your model you can
now then save your model into disk using
spark persistence and here you can see
that I'm saving all the models back into
blob storage now the great thing about
this is that data scientists could train
on a smaller subset of your data or a
smaller cluster and then they could move
give that date that persistent model to
a data engineer to run in a different
cluster so that's it's probably another
use case or it's also great for
production Ising models okay
so now I will just swap to to the slides
okay so we have a train model sitting in
blob storage now we're ready to
productionize it there's multiple ways
of actually production izing models one
is in spark where you can choose between
that batch or streaming inference and
another very common way of production
icing machine learning models is
actually out of spark where you're
actually container izing your model and
potentially wrapping a rest service on
top of this and then so that other
components can actually call into it
we're going to be talking about the in
spark
way of production Ising models for this
is actually a completely separate talk
altogether the only thing that I would
point out is that if you are interested
in this sort of way of production models
take a look at ml leap and M will flow
which are great libraries on how you
would actually do that like exporting
models in Spore
without any sport dependencies and
running it without your spark libraries
so yeah
okay so you've seen ml persistence how
you would actually save the model into
persistent into blob storage the great
feature about this is that a data
scientist could write their code in
Python and a data engineer can Road the
model in Scala so in the real world a
lot of the times they designed this
would write their code in either Python
and R and a data engineer would have to
re-implement everything in a separate
language because that's what their
production environment is is written in
but the great thing about ml persistence
is that it's uniform across all the API
so if a data engineer starting in our
smart car specifically then they can
save it and the data engineer who's
reading it in the Scala API of spark can
read read it back in read back the Train
model the other thing that spark gives
you out of the box is streaming so
structured streaming is the API that you
get from spark
it's a successor of the D streams API if
you've worked with spark for a while and
the great thing about structured
streaming is that the code that you
write for batch is almost identical to
the code that you write for streaming
and the way to think about it is that in
batch you have a finite beta frame while
in streaming you have an infinitely long
data frame or a data frame a piece that
gets appended to so that's how logically
you would think about it when you're
writing code for structured streaming
which i think is pretty cool there's
obviously some caveats so not not
everything that works in batch will work
in streaming but predominantly you will
notice that your code is actually quite
similar okay so so I'm just the demo
model operational part which I'm going
to be demoing
okay so so first I actually would want
to show you the job so here I have a
batch and streaming job already
scheduled and in order to schedule jobs
in spark you just do create job and
specify a number of parameters but I'll
just actually investigate my current job
here which is my batch scoring job
a K once it actually loads
I might shift to my phone Wi-Fi if this
keeps sorry for that
does anyone have questions so far well
I'm transferring my connection great
question so as your studio I would say
is great if you're still starting out
because it has that very simple
interface the drag-and-drop GUI the
thing with spark is that you almost have
to write code so you you have to be
familiar with the API is out of the box
so it's fairly advanced
I guess you advanced ish sort of data
scientists would use spark and the thing
would as your studio it has has a
limitation of the amount of data sets
you can actually train on I think it's
around a gigabyte so you won't be able
to train over terabytes of data using
the mo studio service so it's a great
starting point though so yeah okay so
let me just try to reload my job okay
that must have been the thing I clicked
on okay so here I have my batch job
that's already scheduled and you can see
that I'm specifying a specific cluster
size so the great thing about spark jobs
is that you can have a cluster tailor
fit to that specific job which is very
hard to do if you you're running on
premises and you can see that I've
scheduled a specific notebook and I can
even pass parameters to that notebook
but for this I'm not actually passing
any parameters and you have a number of
different Advanced Options AI
concurrency and that sort of stuff and
timeout
so I'll just load this specific batch
scoring job it's actually quite simple
all I'm doing is just loading some
unlabeled data points for production you
probably want to filter this by when was
the last run of this job but for this
demo I'm just loading it as is I'm
loading my pipeline model for this I'm
just using my random forest pipeline
which I think was the best pipeline
model and I'm just calling it transform
method and saving my results so super
simple notebooks don't be afraid of
batch job like batch jobs are fairly
trivial to do and
usually streaming it's only when you
really have that specific use case um
that low latency inference
so that's batch and I'm just gonna jump
to my streaming demo but before that
I'll just trigger my actual data
generator so which will actually start
streaming so this one's I'm just
literally feeding the data from that
unlabeled data frame into event hubs and
my streaming job should then pick that
up so I'll just open this streaming job
and this specific job is actually a
continuous job it doesn't have an end
point and it you can see that I ran it
last night
and if I open my notebook so here I'm
actually cooking up into Azure event
hubs so the one the key thing to know
about this is that you actually need to
load a third-party library and in order
to do that you actually go here
workspace and I like to put my libraries
in the shared folder and you know create
library and this library you can specify
a specific repository that they're gonna
pull from so for event hubs you need
this specific library which is your
event hub spark library and then you
just say create library and the once you
have that library created you have to
attach that to your cluster where your
streaming job is gonna run so flipping
back to my job so here I you can see
that I'm actually loading up that
specific library and I am retrieving a
set of secrets so my event hub
essentially connection details I'm
loading my pipeline model and I'm
setting up my connection string to event
hubs finally I just connect to my event
hubs by using this command it's called
spark dot read stream and if you're
familiar spark to read a non streaming
data data source you just do spark don't
read and that gives you a data frame
called incoming stream which is
literally a spark data frame but it's a
dreaming spark dataframe so and I'm just
using all the different commands that
you would use almost exactly the same as
batch so I'm just adding a bunch of
columns I'm extracting the body field
and adding a watermark and so on and
here I'm just extracting some JSON
objects and I'm actually doing a static
join between a data frame that's sitting
on my sparks equal table and the
incoming stream so I'd imagine the
incoming stream would just probably have
three fields but for this specific
scenario I actually extracted the fields
out and just match on a specific ID so
that I can actually do an in-stream join
between static and streaming data frames
now I just use my model to use and call
the transform and I'm just filtering on
prediction where it is anomalous and
here I'm just outputting my anomalous
data frames data points into another
event hub in which case the downstream
process can probably act on it like send
an alert or whatever you need to do so
that's pretty much it so it's fairly
simple to actually wire up spark
streaming to event hubs
okay so the data bricks comes out of the
box with a number of developer tooling
so you probably if for the guys who
don't like repeating the same thing
three times using the GUI don't worry
there's a CLI which you can script
everything out that I've just showed you
and it also comes with the rest API if
you if you can't use the CLI for
whatever reason so you can control your
data bricks workspace with with this
tooling now in fact I've actually
scripted out this entire demo so if you
if you want to deploy this demo
literally and authorized the deployment
so literally just run docker run IT and
pass it that container and this will
literally spin up the demo completely
from scratch it will prompt you for your
login details so it'll prompt you for
your subscription obviously and tell you
where ask you where the research script
you want to deploy to and if you're
logged into a number of subscriptions
you can you can point to a specific
subscription and it will just literally
walk through all the scripts to deploy
this solution and I've actually also
given a different top and this which is
the recommendation engine this is
similar similar talk but it's let's
focus on ml Lib and you can also spin up
this demo as well where I'm actually
it's an end-to-end recommendation engine
built on top of azure data bricks so and
if you're not familiar docker you can
also go to the github link and you can
deploy it locally but if if you don't
know docker I highly recommend that you
go try it out okay so more resources
just the apache spark website your as
your native bricks documentation and
this is a great book by the creator of
apache spark mathias area which it which
basically goes around goes deeper into
the spark details i highly recommend
this book
it was recently released this year I
believe I just read the pre-release so
and with that that's that's pretty much
it
there's any wanted questions
yep
okay so you don't get intellisense it's
not that great you can also write in
your favorite IDE so the thing with
spark native for data breaks is that you
have that CLI endpoints so you can
submit jars or Python packages from your
favorite ID like vs code so you're not
confined to writing code in the notebook
so you can and by that regard you can
get debugging out of the box depending
on what's what ID are using oh sorry
the question was can you do debugging in
notebooks and the first one was
intellisense
yeah anyone else have questions yeah
that's a great question in fact a lot of
our clients that we find is struggling
with exactly that Pingdom it's not
necessarily with spark but ml in general
like C ICD with an ml there's actually a
great top that's coming up on Friday
called DevOps for ml or ml for DevOps
which is the last top of the conference
so I definitely encourage you to go to
that but for C ICD because you have your
CLI in your s and endpoint there's no
reason why you can't script out anything
that you need to do via the GUI so you
can certainly build AC ICD pipeline
where it automatically trains your model
or let's say it builds a docker
container upon check-in in fact the
github repos that I have has a very
simple CI CD we're literally rebuilds
the docker container my deployment
docker container upon every check in so
that docker container that you saw up
front is always up-to-date and yeah so
you can see that I have my little CI CD
pipeline there it's actually using Azure
DevOps pipelines which is free unlimited
build minutes for public repos
so anyone else have questions awesome so
I guess if no one has questions that's
that's my top thank you
[Applause]